what's up guys i'm kvhd here on an
absolutely frigid day in the northeast
it's december but that won't stop
autofocus episode 4.
this is a mclaren 720s
you may have heard of it so mclaren
mclaren pretty much exclusively makes
high-end sports cars they have their
their 540 their 570 gt then they have
their super series which includes the
720s
and then they have their million dollar
hyper cars the p1 and the senna so as
you may have seen from my twitter or
instagram i've had a couple days with
the 720s it's been ridiculous here are
my five favorite features number one is
performance everything about this car is
fast now by the numbers you would expect
that 700 plus horsepower weighing around
3000 pounds it's super nimble it's rated
zero to 60 in 2.7 seconds it puts down
big torque numbers this is clearly one
of the fastest rear wheel drive cars
period but here's my favorite part
mclaren is
very very conservative with their
estimates for what the 720s is rated for
it's rated to do 0 to 60 in 2.7 seconds
but there are videos all over youtube of
it doing 2.6 2.5 2.4 it's it's faster
than that off the line there are owners
putting it on dinos and getting bigger
horsepower numbers than mclaren is
claiming the theory is
mclaren doesn't want to make their
million-dollar p1 and sena customers too
angry
because the 720s is actually
just as fast as those cars this 300 000
car is apparently just as fast sometimes
faster around the track than the million
dollar p1 unreal so you probably never
feel the full extent of that awesome
acceleration in that 200 mile an hour
plus top speed especially not me because
i'm driving a 300 000 car that isn't
mine on the streets of new jersey
in the winter
but what i do feel and notice really is
how fast the shifting is with the paddle
shifters it's instant so you want to
accelerate while you're cruising in
sixth or seventh gear you can drop down
two gears real quick as you get on the
gas and it's all super responsive also
for a gas car and for a rear-wheel drive
car it's quick off the line yes but
something you really notice and this is
coming from someone who regularly drives
the p100d
is the 60 to 100 speed that speed after
60 miles an hour is really fast so yeah
it's a fast car again new jersey
potholes cold weather it's so hard to
demo but trust me this is fast so number
two is the arrow now a generally a
supercar shape is designed to cut
through the air as efficiently as
possible
at high speed and they all sort of do
that but this one takes it to another
level you can have crazy numbers on
paper really big horsepower and torque
etc anyone can have big specs but there
are so many little things that you have
to do with aerodynamics that make it
just a little bit faster it starts on
this car with those headlights you saw
in the intro the actual headlights
themselves are just the slits in the
middle and the top and the rest of that
area is actually a carbon fiber lined
opening for air to pass through the
front of the car to cool the brakes so
the air goes through the front past the
wheels through the holes in the door so
these are some of the most incredible
doors to a car i've ever seen as there's
massive slots for air to pass through
them and then when the air finishes over
the back wheels some also goes up past
the engine and out the back over the
rear wing this this whole car is a
teardrop shape around the mid-engine and
you're basically in a cockpit cutting
through the air it's kind of amazing
visibility is also surprisingly good too
when the wing is down but i do have to
say when the wing is up it cuts into
your rear visibility a bit luckily
there's a button to put the wing up or
down at any time it's down by default at
lower speeds but having it up is better
for downforce and it can flip up to
vertical to be used as an air brake from
really high speeds that's actually a
perfect segue into why i had the car in
the first place mclaren partnered with
oneplus to make a mclaren edition phone
the oneplus 6t so their theory is the
same way things like aerodynamics can
make an already fast car faster they've
also done some things for this phone to
make an already fast phone faster than
it already was so there is a new design
with little hints of carbon fiber in the
top and it's got that mclaren orange but
this phone also now has what they're
calling warp charge so an even faster
fast charging and it also now has 10
gigs of ram so thanks to oneplus for
sponsoring this video and getting me in
touch with mclaren for this
all right now back to the car so number
three is the modes now pretty much any
sports car at all nowadays has some sort
of like a comfort mode and a sport mode
maybe a sport plus mode or something
like that but this is a sort of next
level of modular adjustment that i can
appreciate it actually splits the modes
into two mode dials one for handling
with the h up top and one for
performance the p and each of them has
their own comfort sport or track so cs
or t so you can independently decide you
want your handling stuff which is
steering weight suspension traction
control that type of thing to feel more
comfortable while you want the
performance or how much power the engine
is putting down to be more sporty or
vice versa whatever you want and then
anytime you put any one of these in
track mode the card dramatically takes
your entire dashboard and flips it down
to hide all the unnecessary information
and just gives you a new narrow screen
at the top that shows your gear your
rpms and your speed that's it super
badass and there's also a mode called
variable drift control which lets you
literally in the car's display dial in
an angle you want to drift at
but again
new jersey
winter
potholes didn't really get to try that
but number four
is the design this car turns so many
heads not only is it red and a mclaren
and loud but there's just so many cool
unusual bits of design on this car that
look like nothing else the exhaust
lifted way above the road level where
it's more visible and louder the doors
that not only flip up but also have
windows in the top of them so you kind
of have this little sunroof and a little
extra headroom when you're sitting in
the cockpit and this is my favorite
steering wheel of all time in any car
i've ever driven which is pretty
important it's like having a favorite
display of a phone it's the main way you
interact with it all the time so it's
important that you like it the
headlights are pretty mean looking the
whole front end is so low with that
front splitter and also the rear end
whether the wing is up or down is always
a looker so even more than the nsx or
any other car i've driven people are
taking pictures from the sidewalk from
next to you on the road so much snapchat
happening i already get asked if i play
basketball like a lot but i've never
been asked more if i play in the nba
than when getting out of this car and
then once you park this thing i'd say
half the times i came back to it in a
parking lot someone was either waiting
at the car or taking pictures with it or
just wanting to talk to somebody about
it it's kind of hilarious i wish i'd
miked myself up for these conversations
because half the time they were amazing
like conversation starters with people
who used to work with car companies or
they'd test drive cars or they have a
friend with a sports car all kinds of
crazy stuff and then last but not least
number five
all the little things the details the
amazingly geeky
well-considered
details i mean i guess for 300 000
you should consider all the details
but yeah they do i'm talking about the
sound of the engine and the
turbochargers every time you accelerate
the startup sound and just how badass
this car constantly sounds there is a
front trunk that's actually pretty big
bigger than my tesla and i didn't get a
clip of it but the backup camera shows
up on the huge screen behind the
steering wheel which is pretty smart and
the relatively minimal looking interior
despite being surrounded by tech and
even a lot of speakers actually and
possible distractions everywhere and the
fact that when you put the wing up since
it blocks the tail light there's another
light on the wing that replaces it so
you're always visible and just the
amount of carbon fiber in this car from
the front splitter to the headlights to
the engine bay to the rear diffuser
right through the interior on the
steering wheel and everything
driving this car to me feels like tesla
roadster training wheels which is
probably weird to say because i think
most people would probably take this
over a tesla but you can't get over the
fact that it's rear-wheel drive and an
all-wheel drive car to me always feels
more planted and stable and under
control especially when you're really
driving it but bottom line this car is
just insane in so many ways
it's like it has too much power for its
own good i only got to drive it for a
couple of days but honestly you learn a
lot messing with a car like this and i
hope to do it again someday
until then
thanks for watching catch you guys in
the next one
peace